well I'm I'm big into men's rights so
that's what the Channel's about you'll
begin to
get into material as a woman yeah yeah I
think I think that men need to be
advocated for too I think like there's
always women's rights but we don't ever
talk about men okay I agree but like
overall you as a woman who have clearly
historically systematically been
oppressed how can you then say you
advocate for men's right well because I
don't believe I've been a press
no okay I'll give I'll give you an
example
yeah I don't I don't believe women have
been impressed and this woman tonight
men's hands around my throat tonight
leave a place a bar down the street
hands around her throat and said you're
too much for me you're too pretty I I
can't deal with you I've been told that
I was going to get because I didn't want
to get home with someone I've been told
I've got date in my drink because I
don't want to go home with someone and
you're trying to tell me women haven't
been oppressed I don't know not by and
large men men get assaulted too
and I'm saying can I need you to let me
talk okay we're gonna have it we're
gonna have like her like yelling at me
it's not really productive so it's like
wow so I'm saying I'm saying like men
get assaulted and they're not taken
seriously like if a woman gets assault
like what happened with Amber hurt she
came forward people just automatically
believed her and she was able to accuse
a man of things that he didn't even do
and that's a man with power and money
and privilege what happens to the
average guy that happens to you like we
like we had a whole movement called
believe yeah so it's like if that
happened to a rich powerful man what
does that mean for the average guy
and like that doesn't happen to women
like women automatically are believed
where men aren't and like because it
happens from a history like women are in
a place of like lower power so how could
we say that we're at a place of lower
power when we never had to fight in Wars
men were the ones that were forced to go
out and fight and protect women women
didn't even have the option to go and
fight because they were seen as too weak
women didn't actually so you might not
know this the women didn't actually want
the right to vote because it came with
being drafted so if you if you surveyed
women a hundred years ago do you want
the right to vote Yes or No most said no
because they had to be drafted so okay I
didn't they didn't want to do that I
don't know the facts behind that but I
just don't see how that could possibly
be true if they suffrage at you like
movement like how is that suffrage it
was actually started in um New York and
it was started by men it wasn't started
by women okay really yeah it was in
Seneca Falls New York
um I can't remember the exact year off
the top of my head yeah it wasn't
started by it was a group of 300 people
and the majority were men please help me
okay they go please help yeah and so I I
just think men like they're they're not
they're not taken seriously when they
have claims of assault and that's a real
problem
and so even even in this conversation
when I say like that I think men have a
problem like it's always women have to
come forward and say well what about our
problems and we're talking about the
point you're coming across of like men
don't have the voice to be saying oh
I've been assaulted whatever I see that
point especially like being a gay male
or whatever like it takes a lot for
someone to come out and be like okay
I've I've been solid like walking down
the street or whatever but I just think
it's kind of like rude for your argument
to be then that women don't have
oppression or whatever like that no I I
just don't think we have in 2022 you
have so much privilege as a young pretty
girl in my workplace the work of like
hierarchy it's like 75 percent male to
women so do you know do you know why
that is why because men pick harder jobs
men work more hours no no if you look at
so and I'm just saying like if you just
Google like Google what percent of what
percent of women are plumbers what
percent so Plumbing electricians okay I
understand that but that's different
that's society telling men that they
should become plumbers that's not women
not becoming plumbers or getting a
hard-working job so I I used to think
that too right I literally I used to
think that but when you look at
countries that are more so if you look
do a list of countries right and you
pick the countries that are more free
and then do the countries that are the
least free for women and it's pretty
easy to like to pick those you go to the
Scandinavian countries there's more free
if you go to the like Saudi Arabia last
free the pay Gap gets bigger the more
Choice women have which seems to
indicate that women pick jobs that make
less money when they're given more
Choice okay so I haven't looked into
that so I can't really comment on that
yeah
expect you to come into knowing
everything yeah but so I just think a
lot of times the narrative is like that
women are oppressed and I genuinely
think that a lot of men have it harder
than us and we don't advocate for them
like like for example if if I get
married and I get a divorce um who's the
one collecting child support and in the
U.S there are men that commit suicide
over going into so much debt over child
support like like there are women
stealing condoms from the NBA trying to
get pregnant like and so it's just like
these are men's issues that I think are
important I feel like it's very
different like we're in the UK you can't
really I don't think in terms of looking
at America's statistics it shouldn't
really be applied to the UK it's very
it's a it's a very different climate the
UK the UK has similar problems they also
have child support like I've interviewed
men on the channel That come forward and
say like yeah that girl tried to get
like like she told me she was on birth
control to try to get pregnant it's
definitely an issue and like I've heard
of that before but that is very based on
the individual I don't know I just think
as a woman are you saying you're not a
feminist no I wouldn't call myself a
feminist because I just I think in 2022
what am I fighting for we have all the
rights okay Alex and that's crazy
but right do I not have so do you do you
go to nightclubs no no don't drink there
you go so I think that is mainly your
issue so you you don't go to nightclubs
you don't put yourself and I guess it's
kind of like oh just a woman put herself
in that position but it's not if you're
going on a night out you're having fun
that's you deciding I'm gonna go out
with my friends and then a man a man is
taking advantage of you you shouldn't
then be blamed for oh I wore a short
dress like I was going hard having fun
like before you were saying if a girl
wears red lipstick like she's asking for
it no I didn't say that we have the
recording so so no I'm not saying yeah
so I didn't say she along the lines no
no I wasn't taking asking for it I'm
saying that's what it indicates sexual
arousal I'm saying so like I think
that's weird because in my head as a
student who studies fashion red lipstick
I've seen as like fashionable it's like
a catwalk like red lipstick is a very
prominent thing in fashion it's not oh
I'm I'm sexually active like I want
people to have sex with me it might not
be intentional but like there's reasons
that like like that we put the makeup on
the way we do it like like like like
mascara mascara indicates bigger eyes
like men are attracted to bigger eyes
see like to me you want to come in I
just think that's down to you like if
your boy mascara on to have bigger eyes
and you're thinking oh I'm gonna have
bigger eyes to attract a man and that's
down to you did you know what's
interesting when I do these interviews
like it's not it's not the men who are
rude to me it's always the women and
it's always like I almost got like a
girl was trying to attack me like
honestly like I'm saying like genuinely
I'm more afraid of getting attacked by
women than I am by men but I just think
that's because you're not showing
yourself as wanting like for a woman I
just think that's because you're not
advocating for women to have like but it
shouldn't be like I am allowed to have a
different opinion than a woman so like I
think as women if you're really a
feminist you should support women that
have different opinions than you I think
and so I'm saying like when I when I
when I can I just finish like yeah so
like when I'm doing these streetone
interviews it's very frustrating because
the women that say they're advocating
for me are the same ones trying to throw
hands because the people that are
advocating for you you're completely
backfiring to them and saying you're not
advocating for women at all no I'm
saying they're not advocating for me
because I should be like it's a
conversation for yourself you're saying
you're not a feminist so you don't want
equal rights you just wanted no no
that's not what I said I'm saying we
have you I'm saying oh feminist sorry
I'm not a feminist because we have all
the rights we need
like so I'm asking what law or policy do
we need in 2022 I just think it should
be easy because like we're so oppressed
so what's what's one okay well I don't
know a price intensive laws but I know a
price in terms of society you said you
don't go clubbing so my friends they go
clubbing and they get sexually abused
almost people grab them people touch
them and it's inappropriate you don't
men are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime you're not entitled to
safety yeah like if you choose to go
into like a city in a nightclub like men
are assaulted too men can get punched
get into fights if they're so it's like
we both have problems but more often
than not I mean this is very
generalizing but if a man gets into an
altercation with another man more often
than not this is very generalizing but
in the terms of a situation like in a
nightclub or whatever so say I was in a
night club before two guys got into a
fight that was an altercation between
them two like being men they were
fighting they were arguing it was
violence whereas like if an altercation
happened with a woman it would be
because he was such a inappropriate that
she was saying no stop it and he would
get angry because he couldn't get the
way he wanted can I give you a stat that
you might not know yeah so so so so so
let's let's talk about abusive
relationships so most abusive
relationships are are they're both
abusive meaning the man's hitting the
woman and the woman's hitting the mat
but in in cases where it's one-sided
abuse meaning someone's hitting and the
other is not hitting back women do it
more than men okay
so it's like when I see stats like this
and and it's still like that women
men have a hard time coming
another example tonight I'm here with
Jesse right and Jesse was literally like
we got it on camera this girl was like
pushing him and like all over him and if
that happened to me like I they would
cry assault right but for him like
nobody says anything yeah and so it's
like like girls can kind of get away
with that stuff where guys everyone
agrees it's wrong I do think that's a
hard statistic come by because
realistically like the difference is
even a night she's trying to get girls
to come forward and be like what you're
saying is wrong like you're not really
advocating for women's rights and even
the women are too afraid to come over to
you and talk to you well I don't know
why they're afraid like it's quite like
I don't
caught theology yeah because you are
personally not even like am I am I rude
to you like I've been very polite to me
but like to the women you you have been
rude how have I been rude when someone
threatened to punch me okay but I know
it hasn't fashioned trying to punch you
yeah but she said I don't want to be
near you like that's kind of rude right
it is kind of weird but when you're like
I'm asking saying that her experience of
being touched in a club where she didn't
want to be touched it's invalid you were
saying oh I didn't I didn't say it was
invalid that's not what I said okay but
you kind of push her away and neglected
it like it's not really an issue like
you wanted to talk about men I'm saying
I'm saying I don't think that's okay I
don't I think that's wrong but when you
go out into a nightclub like you know
there's a possibility that'll happen but
there shouldn't be a possibility I'm
saying I'm saying it happens to men and
women it happens to both like like just
today I went out with Jesse right and I
I was threatened right Jesse protected
me that was a privilege as a woman that
I got this girl comes up to him and has
his hands all over her hands all over
him like because he's a guy people just
accept it yeah I know I don't think
people like sat here it's a hard but I
think as a woman it's more often that it
happens I don't know because
men are more likely to be in Mexico
sticks so I guess I'm just gonna have to
go because I I don't really know enough
to kind of battle with you on this yeah
yeah okay I think I appreciate I
appreciate your knowledge like I
understand that you have more like
knowledge as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible